Speaker 1: Barack Obama accurately called out the
toxic left at a very interesting event called the
Obama Foundation summit yesterday. Obama now
you remember that guy. I have to tell you,
I think what Barack Obama says here is pretty
damn accurate. I have made clear the toxic left
is a small part of the left, but it exists and
it's really destructive and counterproductive.
Barack Obama in this clip we're going to look
at. Hard to imagine a more accurate assessment
of this sliver of the left. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: You know, this this idea of purity and
you're never compromised and you're always
politically broke and all that stuff. You
should get over that quickly. The world the
world is messy and there are ambiguities and
people who do really good stuff. Have flaws.
People who you are fighting. May love their kids.
And you know. Share certain things with you. And
I think that one danger I see among young people,
particularly on college campuses, Molly and I talk
about this. Yeah, goes to school with my daughter.
But I do get a sense sometimes now among certain
young people and this is accelerated by social
media, there is this sense sometimes
of the way of me making change is to
be as judgmental as possible about other people.
Speaker 1: Folks, this is verbatim the stuff I've
been saying for four years on the show. These are
genuinely wise words. I've been careful to say.
There is a small but very loud part of the left.
The right is almost completely bonkers. Nuts.
That's clear. That's a clear part of the show. But
there is this slice of the left that's very loud,
and they will allow the perfect to become the
enemy of the good. They will use purity tests.
They will dismiss entire groups of people
over the narcissism of what we sometimes
call small differences. And in my universe,
in the left media platform, they often try to
ruin what people like me and others are doing
because we're not perfect by their standard.
And this is part of why the left loses doesn't
win as much as we could. Let's continue.
Speaker 2: And that's enough. Like if I tweet or
hashtag about how you didn't do something right or
use the word wrong verb, or then I can sit back
and feel pretty good about myself because, man,
you see how woke I was? I called you out there.
Get on TV. Watch my show. Watch. Grown ish.
You know, that's not that's not activism.
That's not bringing about change. You know,
if all you're doing is casting stones.
Uh. You know, you're probably not going
to get that far. That's easy to do.
Speaker 1: There are lots of people who
I know don't like this. And these are the same
people that get mad at me sometimes when I say,
hey, you know, it might be better to get this win
a tangible step forward, but we might benefit from
that even if it's not perfect or even if some of
the people helping us get this win don't agree
with us about this other area here, particularly
on some of these cultural issues. And the way I
understand what the former president is saying is
that there are shared values and desires that are
much broader than our exact political orientation.
You might ask me about my position on 50 different
issues, and you and I might only agree on 30, but
there are some overriding values that we share,
particularly that the right doesn't. And there's
going to be ambiguity, there are contradictions.
We are, you know, as much as we all like to
be consistent. You know, when I say to you,
hey, listen. If I don't praise or blame a
Republican for gas prices, then I have to
try to be consistent and apply the same standard
to a Democratic president. We're all trying to be
consistent, but there are contradictions and there
are ambiguities. And some of them come from all
sorts of different things in our background or our
upbringing or education or whatever the case may
be. The nuance is great, but we can't allow those
differences to get in the way of the progress that
is available for all of us to take. And this
includes things like. To be perfectly frank,
the idea of If it's not Bernie, then
I don't care if it's Hillary or Trump.
It's sort of all the same. Why were
those people proven wrong? And again,
it's a small slice of the left, but I love this.
I think Barack Obama is absolutely spot on here.